CNN is in shambles and has fired its
much celebrated new CEO Chris Licht
after only a year attempting to fix CNN
but dramatically damaging it in the
process this is a major media story in
the United States whatever your media
diet consists of this actually is a
story that will have sort of cascading
impact all across the media ecosystem so
let's discuss it it was indeed a short
Reign for Chris Licht we were told he's
going to come in he's going to fix CNN
which has become apparently two
left-wing and make it more appealing to
all sides of the political Spectrum the
Associated Press reporting
CNN ousts CEO Chris Licht after a brief
tumultuous tenure the chief executive
pushed out of a job Wednesday faced
mounting problems in his first year
leading the struggling Network
viewership and profits were declining
very important aspect to evaluating his
job by CNN programming blunders were
growing and the Network's journalists
were losing confidence by the day Chris
licht's very bad year culminated in a
damning magazine profile last week it's
in the Atlantic I recommend you check it
out it's quite interesting and just a
few days later his tumultuous 13-month
tenure is over 51 year old Licht was
informed of his ouster Wednesday morning
and it was announced to the staff at the
daily editorial meeting the same place
were licked two days earlier said he
would quote fight like hell to earn the
trust of those around him the executive
who hired and fired lick that's David
saslav the CEO of CNN parent company
Warner Brothers Discovery accepted some
of the blame for the turmoil over the
last year and has appointed a
four-person interim leadership team
zazlev promised CNN staff a thorough
search for licht's replacement here's
the announcement happening on CNN
we have news now to report involving our
own network news to us here at CNN and
you at home CNN's chairman and CEO Chris
Licht is leaving the network right took
over the network a little over a year
ago David zazlov the chairman of CNN's
parent company Warner Brothers Discovery
he just made the announcement at the
network editorial meeting for now a
leadership team will take click's place
led by Amy and tell us who's the
Executive Vice President of talent and
content development along with Virginia
Mosley the EVP of editorial Eric
shirling our programming EVP and David
Levy our new Chief Operating Officer
right Sarah very very exciting stuff so
here's the story
a number of reasons for this firing and
they all make sense plummeting ratings I
mean okay at the end of the day this is
a for-profit media Outlet ratings were a
disaster journalistic blunders internal
strife all of it but one of the most
important aspects of this is that the
staff at CNN obviously lost confidence
in this guy the audience has been
increasingly confused about what on
Earth is happening at CNN and the brand
has been embarrassed and it is a brand
that for a very long time I mean listen
I don't take pleasure in this I'm going
to give you my analysis in a moment but
I remember being a kid and seeing on CNN
important moments you know when I think
back to the early 90s and the mid 90s I
remember the first Iraq War
I remember
um the assassination of Israeli Prime
Minister Rabin
I remember the Clinton impeachment and
Monica Lewinsky situation in the mid 90s
all of it was brought by CNN this is
pre-fox news even existing and there was
a certain gravitas when it comes to what
CNN did and maybe still does best I
don't know uh which is those types of
events licht's biggest mistake was that
he misread the mood of the country and
the media landscape and instead of
saying oh we need to bring CNN back to
primarily being that thing which I
remember from when I was a kid it was
the Assumption from lick that CNN lost
viewers because it had become too
liberal and anti-trump and the solution
I guess that Chris Licht thought was
appropriate was let's show both sides
let's Court Republicans let's bring on
more Republican strategists and former
Trump staffers and others and do this
Trump Town Hall which was I mean
arguably there was no way that was going
to go well and Licht did that
ignoring that CNN's core audience wasn't
aching for right-wing nuttery it just
there was not actually a demand for
right-wing nuttery from the audience
Licht also underestimated the
competition from Fox and MSNBC in the
sense of the more ideologically based
cable news networks Fox News carving out
a right-wing editorial position
MSNBC carving out a center-left sort of
Democratic party establishment position
and so the idea that CNN is just going
to bring in some Trump people and then
all of a sudden we're going to have an
ideological platform that will attract
viewers it simply wasn't happening and
this led to a whole bunch of different
fiascos that damaged CNN's credibility
and its Integrity yes the Trump Town
Hall widely criticized as a softball
platform for Trump even though in her
defense anchor Caitlyn Collins did do
some of what was possible to do but it's
such a fire hose of misinformation from
Trump
and the environment was not right with a
crowd full of trump sycophants
titillated in the audience it just
didn't go well and in one sense it was a
ratings flop in another sense it was
journalistically problematic and
immediately people started calling for
Lick's resignation so I do think this
was necessary and it was obvious only to
stop the bleeding there is no guarantee
it's not enough CNN still has to figure
out how do we deal with the challenges
and the uncertainties the post-trump era
although it might again become a trump
era what's the vision that CNN might
articulate I don't know what the answer
is if I were CNN
and I know nothing about cable news
programming or any of it I would invest
in quality journalism diverse voices and
I don't mean diversity in the sense of
make sure you've got an Asian woman and
a black guy I'm not talking about that
type of diversity I mean diversity in
terms of types of Journalism and
Innovative formats one of the best
things CNN ever did quite frankly and
this is very much a departure from what
CNN used to be known for was bring
Anthony Bourdain's program to CNN and
Anthony Bourdain's life tragically
ending of course but figure out what's
the unique value proposition just being
like well we we've become known as an
anti-trump voice let's bring on some
right Wingers it's it's just it's vapid
it's not going to work
um no desire to see CNN fail and in fact
although I'm critical of the entire
apparatus of for-profit 24-hour cable
news
for all the reasons many of you know
when you have to fill 24 hours you do
low effort stuff and then the quality
degrades yeah I've talked about all
these things but I don't want there to
only be two major cable news networks I
think more is better as a general rule
so shambles at CNN let's now talk about
Mike Pence